Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
[Music]
Real Talk friendly Automotive the
sponsors of this segment is making a
huge impact on this community let's
welcome cfo's Tyler Corder who is
introducing us to a very important
organization led by a very important
lovely lady right that's right so we
have brought Cherie today she's the
founder of real talk and real talk what
they really focus on is disadvantaged
youth in our community there's a lot of
disability they're considered
disadvantaged based on you know their
economic situation or their family
situation or even just the neighborhood
they're in they don't have the
opportunities that some other people
have and what Cherie's organization does
is they they bring in mentors and
speakers to help these people make good
decisions and uh and and give them some
opportunities to get involved in
activities some positive direction in
life so they hopefully have a chance for
success and that's why we love what
Cherie does and real talks I wanted to
bring her on talk about that I'm so glad
you're here this is really important so
what is real talk mean to you define
that for people out there positive
changes in the community and the kids
that's what life is about outright some
of these kids aren't afforded they're
the things that other kids are afforded
and you know we want to make sure that
we provide that you know growing up from
a family of 12 myself I understand what
it is not to have so my duty is to give
back to make sure that I can give the
tools to these kids to become productive
citizens and take away their excuses if
we give them tools and they don't take
the opportunity to use the tools then
there's no change so it's all about
change if we change one child one family
one ex-offender we've done our job the
domino effect right absolutely now you
are UNLV graduate because softball went
to the Olympics so you can Inspire these
kids yourself um how does the what's the
approach like when the coaches are going
to talk to the kids is it scared
straight or is it gentle how are we
doing it you know it's just real talk
like we're sitting here we're having a
conversation you know these ex-felons
that we use or people from the system we
use them to share their testimony with
the kids to let them know you you can do
it my way or you can do it the right way
right and with those testimonies the
kids are going to hear they take
something away from it and it's totally
up to them after that because life is
about choices so if I express to you one
way that didn't work for me
then you should look at the other way
that's going to work better for you in
the future so it's all about choices and
that's the thing we're trying to preach
to these kids like you have to
understand right from wrong and knowing
that there's no excuse because you have
to come to that point where I want to do
better I don't want to do time like Mr
Jason did or Mr Ralph did exactly and
providing them those that extra push
after they listen to those testimonies
you have to go home so what we want to
do is give you something to go home too
so we're going to pay for you up to 150
a month to get involved in any activity
you want as long as you have a 2.0 with
passing grades remain in compliance
we're going to fund you because I don't
want to hear your excuses
wow
okay
realtalkyip.org okay thank you for your
work thank you Tyler oh that's great we
want to thank Finley Automotive Group
for being one of our Community Pride
partners